you try to slow down a fast protein like
changing whey into a mixture of whey and
casein doesn't seem to really do much if
you try to speed up a very slow protein
by going from a whole egg to an egg
white again it doesn't really seem to do
much and when we look at the totality of
the evidence here uh it just doesn't
look like it makes a lot of sense to to
lose sleep over how quickly or slowly
your proteins are digesting whether
we're talking about a daytime feeding or
a nighttime feeding the really important
thing here with any protein feeding is
like i mentioned earlier we need to make
sure that there's enough leucine that
we're going to get a nice robust spike
in leucine whether it happens very
quickly or it takes some time to
accumulate in the blood that's not that
doesn't seem to be a major concern we
just need to make sure that in the hours
that follow that feeding
are we going to get a robust leucine
response and essential amino acid
response as long as those are
accumulating in the blood and reaching
relatively high levels uh then we should
be initiating muscle protein synthesis
and we should have the raw materials to
build new muscle proteins um so we
definitely want to get out of that
mindset of trying to really micromanage
these amino acid responses and these
absorption times it's probably
a situation where as you often say the
juice isn't really worth the squeeze and
all the stress that goes into it so we
need enough leucine we need enough
essential amino acids we need good
enough digestibility and absorption
rates for this protein for a lot
to allow them to accumulate in the blood
but we don't need it to be optimized we
just need it to be good enough it just
hap we just need enough accumulation of
those things to make it work so a faster
peak a higher peak more leucine more
essential amino acids they will not
always translate to better outcomes and
the end points that we really care about
which is building muscle mass uh or you
know
insert whatever your goal happens to be
but when it comes to hypertrophy good
enough is good enough when it comes to
digestion rate uh absorption rate
digestibility and the overall content of
leucine and essential amino acids so uh
like i said
those are kind of the key things we're
looking for and it's really not
difficult to find a protein source that
enables
a maximal or nearly maximal response
that we're looking for here uh you know
uh so
i understand why people like to look
into some of the mechanistic research on
you know plasma leucine responses or
plasma essential amino acid responses
and try to extrapolate i certainly
understand why people try to extrapolate
from some of those very short window
studies looking at muscle protein
synthesis but when you look at the
longitudinal studies looking at actually
building muscle tissue over time
frankly it just doesn't seem to matter
that much
so i i kind of briefly alluded to that
when i was talking about nighttime
protein but i wanted to take a moment to
elaborate and explain why i really don't
sweat over it and then once again as i
mentioned last week
even if we found that all of this stuff
mattered a lot
you could maybe use that information at
breakfast and then everything else goes
out the window because when you're
eating a particular protein source if
you have other things in the meal other
carbohydrate other fat other fiber
that's going to basically eliminate the
utility of pretty much all the research
i just mentioned because it drastically
alters
absorption times and the same thing goes
for any previous meal so if you had
breakfast at nine in the morning and
you're fretting over the speed of your
protein source that you're going to
consume consume for lunch at like noon
or 1 pm
it you don't really know based on the
research what the digestion absorption
rate is going to be because it's going
to be impacted by the previous meal
anyway so doesn't make a lot of sense to
stress over